it's in the early hours that visitors
flock to the Coliseum but there was no
escaping the baking sun and by
mid-morning many preferred to stay
indoors and not many stopped to look at
Christina milakovich's artwork she
hasn't made any sales an unusual
situation during this High season
it's too hot usually we are 25 artists
on the Square but since this unbearable
heat has started 90 percent of the
visitors come late afternoon and into
the evening I decided to come today
during the day but it's a big sacrifice
and a warning that in the coming days
Ill get worse this is the second heat
wave to hit southern Europe this summer
and it's hotter than the first
umbrellas and hats are selling like hot
cakes and Rome's fountains are perhaps
the most appreciated sites these days
the Italian government has issued a red
alert in 16 cities across the country
meaning that there are serious health
risks not only for the elderly and the
most vulnerable but for the entire
population it also warns that in the
next 48 hours the temperatures will
continue to rise
tourists are also being advised to be
careful during the hot hours of the day
and to avoid direct sunlight not the
best time to visit Rome says Jenna who
comes from much cooler northern France
we were discussing this earlier it's
going to get worse and worse it's the
same in France there are big changes in
the weather
by late afternoon the visitors were back
on the streets and the Cure the pantheon
grew longer
Diego told us he fears the coming days
as the thermometer continues to rise
this year has seen the highest number of
tourists since the pandemic but another
record is also about to be broken with
temperatures reaching nearly 50 degrees
Celsius expected in parts of Italy
during the coming days
Al Jazeera Rome